All right.
Here we go.
[upbeat music]
My name's Daryl Smith.
My name is Preston Smith.
I'm the scientific glass blower.
I'm the senior scientific
glassblower at Yale University
housed in the chemistry
department.
They opened the shop in 1924.
It's very critical for research
to have somebody on site.
There's a vast variety
of scientific glassware
that researchers use.
They're doing unique research,
so sometimes it takes
unique glassware.
Some of it's standard
catalog items,
some of it's modifications
of a standard item,
and sometimes it's
a very unique design.
I had this novelty
item called bubble machine
where the liquid goes through
the air return captures
some of the liquid
and it goes up
through a small tube,
so I incorporated that
into a wine decanter.
You have to get the nozzles
and everything just right
or the flow won't continue.
It won't pull the liquid
back up through and around.
So you constantly
have to test it and see,
and then you have to go back
and adjust it.
There we go.
This particular project,
I've made a couple
of different versions
to see which one would work
best.
It's not something
I've seen before,
so it's a little bit
of trial and error,
and you expect that going in.
So you try something,
and it's like,
"Well, I should have
made that first."
So you just do it again.
This should be spun to this side
over here.
Being able to physically
hold the thing
and see it
and look at the sketch
and then look at the piece
you made
and it matches and it looks like
what was envisioned, it's
a really cool process to see
that and actually be like,
"Okay, I did it right."
There are less
and less
opportunities for young
people to learn this craft,
and so it's really a thrill
to pass it on to my son.
It's very rewarding to work
with my father.
He's taught me so much
and it's cool to be able
to take what he's taught
me and continue
to evolve it and then carry
on the legacy in a way.
Working here with the
researchers and working
with people that request gifts,
you're real close to
the end user and you get
some immediate feedback.
When I finish it,
and I know this works well,
that's going to be
very satisfying.